i'm here with jesse rowe of of summit
prep you teach what classes do you teach
i teach algebra geometry and algebra 2.
and now you're with us luckily for the
summer doing a whole bunch of stuff as a
teaching fellow yeah as a teaching
fellow i've been helping with organizing
and developing new content mostly on the
exercise side side of the site and the
reason why we're doing this right now is
you had some very interesting ideas or
questions
yeah so as an algebra teacher when i
introduced that concept of algebra to
students i get a lot of questions one of
those questions is what's the difference
between an equation and a function
the difference between an equation
versus
a function that's that's it's an
interesting question let's pause it and
see let's let the let the viewers try to
think about it a little bit and then and
then maybe we'll give a stab at it
sounds great
so sal how would you answer this
question what's the difference between
an equation and a function
let me let me think about it a little
bit so let me think i i think there's
probably equations that are that are not
functions and functions that are not
equations and they're probably things
that are both so let me think of it that
way so let's first think of so i'm going
to draw if this is the world of
equations right over here
this is the world of equations so this
is equations
equations and then over here is the
world of functions
that's the world of functions i do think
there is some overlap we'll think it
through what where the overlap is
the world of functions so an equation
that is not a function that's sitting
out here i think you know a simple one
would be something like
is something that like x
plus 3 is equal to 10. i'm not
explicitly kind of talking about inputs
and outputs or relationship between
variables i'm just stating an
equivalence the the the expression x
plus 3 is equal to
10. so this
i think traditionally would just be an
equation would not be a function
functions functions essentially talk
about relationships between variables
you get one or more input variables and
will give you only one output variable
uh output value and so you could have
something like and you can define a
function and we'll do that in a second
you could define a function as an
equation but you can define a function a
whole bunch of ways you can visually
define a function maybe as a as a graph
so
something like this where and maybe i
actually mark off the values so that's
one two three
those are the potential x values and and
then on the vertical axis i show what
the value of my function is going to be
literally my function of x maybe that is
3 and maybe this function is defined for
all non-negative values so this is 0
of x and so let me just draw so this
right over here
at least for what i've drawn so far
defines that function i didn't even have
to use an equal sign if x is 2
if x is 2 at least the way i drew it y
is equal to 3. you give me that input i
gave you the value of only one output so
that would be a legitimate function
definition another function definition
would be very similar to what you do in
a computer program
something like
you know if you input you input the day
so let's say that you input the day of
the week
you input the day of the week and if
day
is equal to monday
monday maybe you output
output cereal so that's what we're going
to
we're going to eat that day and
otherwise otherwise you output
otherwise you output meatloaf so this
would would also
would also be a function where we only
have one output for any one day of the
week we're only saying we can only tell
you cereal or meatloaf or not there's no
days where you are eating both cereal
and meatloaf which sounds kind of kind
of repulsive and and then if i were to
think about
if i were to think about something that
could be an equation or a function i
guess what i think about is a an
equation is something that can be used
to define a function so for example we
could say that y
y is equal to
4x
minus 10. this is a potential definition
for defining y as a function of x you
give me any value of x then i can find
the corresponding value of y so this is
this is at least how how i would think
about it